Did you know there was a remake of
psycho in 1998 starring Vince Vaughn as
Norman Bates?
I think we're all in our private traps.
Clampton.
It was a commercial and critical
failure.
It's more or less a shot for shot
remake,
which makes for a cool case study into
how the original psycho worked so well.
We can compare the two movies,
look at the subtle differences and see
why those differences matter and why it
made the original site goes so much
better.
Let's talk specifically about the
ending.
How did the original end,
what it hitchcock leave us with?
Most people remember the look to the
camera from Norman Bates,
but it really ends with the car getting
pulled out of the mud.
The shot leaves a very bad taste in our
mouths because we know what's in the
trunk,
not to mention it's filmed very off
center and it's coming right towards us.
The remake starts the ending in a
similar way,
but it ends by panning out to a
landscape as the credits roll.
This completely ruins the ending.
We're supposed to end feeling disgusted
and uncomfortable,
but the pan reintroduced this us back
into the world with its familiar
landscapes and cars.
Driving by the original psycho ending is
great because it's sickening.
If the camera moves away from the
sickening image and ends with the
familiar were moved from the story and
the murder and are reintroduced back
into society.
That's no way to end the movie.
The psycho remake ending is closer to
the riding,
into the sunset kind of movie ending.
This is a kind of shot where we're
leaving the original story and get
reintroduced into the world.
Normally it's also shot with our main
characters who went through some sort of
ordeal physically moving away from the
camera to continue their journey.
The western popularize this kind of
ending,
but it's still very common in modern
movies just with a few tweaks nowadays.
It can be a car instead of a horse or a
street corner instead of a picture ask
sunset.
It's a very comforting ending.
We see something familiar and it's a
cinematic cue that the story is over and
we're back to the real world.
12 angry men ends with the men who all
came together to pronounce the kid
innocent,
going back into the real world,
a world where the American judicial
system works and people are only
convicted if they actually committed the
crime.
It's a comforting ending and it
compliments the field.
Good theme that even the most stubborn
people can listen to reason and change
their minds.
I'll be at not so easily and not so
nicely,
but I'm not saying that all riding into
the sunset endings are feel good.
How about having a serial killer walk
back into society now?
That's an eerie ending.
I do wish we could chat.
I'm having an old fat
in a very similar way.
Doors closing at the end makes for a
nice symbol to end the movie.
There's a physical separation now
literally closing the door on an
adventure.
Also,
very common.
You can even use it to separate two main
characters within the story,
which is what Francis Coppola did and
perhaps the most famous movie ending of
all time.
Also,
the searchers which has an opening shot
that starts at the doorway with John
Wayne coming in from the desert,
and then the ending shot shows him
leaving through the same doorway.
This ending symbolizes our hero
returning to the wilderness from which
he came.
Another comment ending is when the
ending shot relates to the opening shot.
There's a great super cut of opening and
closing shots of movies shown side by
side on Vimeo and a lot of them relate
to each other.
The goal of this kind of ending is to
show a shot similar to the opening shot,
but now that you've seen the movie,
it should evoke a different feeling for
you.
The opening shot is the first
impression.
The movie tells its story and the movie
ends with something similar to what it
started with.
The last shot will always feel different
because after the movie tells its story
to shot has an entirely different
meaning.
With the Godfather sql,
the shot is the same,
but Michael Corleone is not and he looks
at two in gone.
Girl,
he uses violent imagery to refer to his
wife.
Picture of cracking or lovely skull
spoiling our brains,
trying to get answers,
and by the last shot we know why.
It's a fun way to look at movies because
the ending could potentially some of the
main ideas of the movie.
The difference between the opening and
the closing is that the opening shot
hints at the main ideas and the ending
reinforces them.
It's as if the director is highlighting
the most important part of the movie.
So go watch your favorite movie ending
again.
Maybe look for a symbol.
What do you think the feathers
symbolizes in forrest gump?
There's no right or wrong answer,
but we know what the director wants you
to notice.
What mood does the ending leave you
with?
That's the most important feeling of the
movie because what you walk out of the
theater feeling is what matters.
So give it a try.
And with that I leave you with a
simpsons parody of the godfather ending
because I love the simpsons.
Thanks for watching.